Ob ja oder nein, nach diesem Video
wirst du vielleicht
anders darüber denken.
*Titelmusik*
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Vor etwa einem Jahr hielt ich hier
bei schönschlau
ein flammendes Plädoyer
für mehr Empathie.
Mit dem Argument, dass Empathie
ein bemerkenswertes Produkt
unserer Evolution ist.
Und eine wichtige Grundlage
für unser soziales Zusammenleben.
Und das Empathie
uns erst zu Menschen macht.
Uns von Tieren unterscheidet.
Aber eins haben und die Tiere voraus.
Und zwar: Sie handeln immer logisch.
Selbst wenn sie
kein Verständnis für Logik haben.
Sie tun, was sie tun müssen,
um Nahrung zu besorgen,
um ihren Nachwuchs zu beschützen,
um zu überleben.
Der Mensch aber kann rational
aber auch
ziemlich irrational handeln.
Und Empathie ist ein Grund dafür.
Heute widmen wir uns also mal
der dunklen Seite der Empathie.
In den achtziger Jahren wurde
die Empathie-Altruismus-Hypothese
populär.
Sprich Empathie, also unsere
Fähigkeit uns in andere Menschen
hinein zu versetzen, mit ihnen
mit zu fühlen, fördert Altruismus -
also das selbstlose einsetzen für
das Wohlergehen unserer Mitmenschen.
Kurz Empathie = Hilfsbereitschaft.
Doch das stimmt nicht immer.
Stellt euch vor ihr seid shoppen
in der Fußgängerzone.
Dann sitzt da ein alter Mann
mit amputierten Beinen,
traurigem Gesicht
und bettelt nach Geld.
Ganz ehrlich, wie viele von euch
schauen da lieber weg?
Es ist nichts ungewöhnliches, sich
bei einem solchen Anblick abzuwenden.
Aber der Grund dafür ist nicht,
dass wir gefühlskalt sind,
sondern genau das Gegenteil.
Unsere Empathie, unser Mitgefühl,
kann uns leicht überfordern.
Diese Überforderung kann dazu führen,
dass wir uns
moralisch fragwürdig verhalten.
Wir helfen dem Bettler
nicht nur nicht,
sondern wir schaffen es
noch nicht mal, ihn anzuschauen.
Wenn mitfühlen zu mitleiden wird,
kommt es zu sog. emphatischen Stress.
Der ist Berufsalltag
für Krankenpfleger, Ärzte,
Therapeuten oder Sozialarbeiter.
Wie geht man damit um?
Nicht selten mit Gleichgültigkeit
bis hin zu Zynismus.
Aber wenn man sich anschaut,
wie Empathie im Gehirn entsteht,
sieht man, dass man
nicht zwingend mitfühlen muss,
um nachzuvollziehen,
was ein anderer Mensch denkt.
Man unterscheidet
zwischen emphatischem mitfühlen
und mentalisieren.
Wenn ich mentalisere, dann denke ich
darüber nach, was du denkst.
Was weißt du? Was hast du vor?
Wie könnte ich das beeinflussen?
Wer unsere Videos
zur Dunklen Triade gesehen hat,
vor allem das zu Machiavellismus,
der weiß, dass ein empathieloser,
manipulativer Mensch
dazu in der Lage sein kann,
einem Mitmenschen genau das zu sagen,
was der hören möchte.
Dafür muss man dazu in der Lage sein,
nachzuvollziehen,
was der andere denkt. Und fühlt.
D.h. aber nicht zwingend,
dass man mitfühlen muss.
Empathisches mitfühlen
und mentalisieren
sind sogar neuronal unterscheidbar.
Beim emotionalen Mitfühlen
werden andere Gehirnregionen aktiv,
als beim gedanklichen
Perspektivenwechsel.
Apropos Dunkle Triade,
der Psychologe Paul Bloom
geht noch einen Schritt weiter.
Er behauptet, dass Psychopathen
nicht an einem Mangel
an Empathie leiden,
sondern möglicherweise
an einer krankhaften Sucht danach.
Nehmen wir einen Sadisten, der Freude
am Leid eines anderen verspürt.
Dann ist das ja so, weil er sich
so gut in das Leid
des anderen Menschen
hinein fühlen kann.
Und Empathie hat
noch eine Kehrseite,
die ganz eng mit ihren
positiven Folgen verknüpft ist.
Es ist ganz natürlich, dass wir mit
Menschen, die uns ähnlich sind,
viel besser mitfühlen können
als mit Menschen,
mit denen wir wenig gemeinsam haben.
Die Folge ist,
dass wir andere Menschen ausgrenzen
oder abwerten, die nicht
zu unserer eigenen Gruppe gehören.
Außerdem macht uns Empathie
oft unglaublich irrational.
Zum Beispiel
ist es nicht ungewöhnlich,
dass uns das Schicksal
eines einzelnen Menschen
stärker berührt als das von vielen.
Wenn hunderte Flüchtlinge
im Mittelmeer ertrinken,
dann bewegt es Menschen weniger
als ein Foto eines einzelnen Jungen,
der tot am Strand liegt.
Wir neigen außerdem dazu,
unser Mitgefühl
vor allem Underdogs
und Außenseitern zu geben.
Mit ein Grund dafür,
dass Trump sich in seinem Wahlkampf
als Opfer des Establishment
und der Fakenews inszenieren konnte.
Das Mitfühlen mit Opfern
wird auf die Spitze getrieben,
in der Art und Weise,
wie wir mit Tieren mitfühlen.
Nach unserem Verständnis
sind Tiere unschuldig.
Sie verfolgen keine unmoralischen
Absichten außer das Überleben.
So kann man immer wieder beobachten,
dass Menschen von Schicksalen
einzelner Tiere stärker bewegt
werden, als z.B. vom Krieg in Syrien.
Sei es der Gorilla Harambe
für den anscheinend manche lieber
ein Kind hätten sterben sehen
oder der Löwe Cecil,
der Jimmy Kimmel vor laufender Kamera
zum Weinen brachte.
Rational ist was anderes.
Also nicht, dass ich nicht traurig
bin darüber, dass ein Zahnarzt
zu seiner eigenen Belustigung Löwen
tötet - aber wenn man darüber weint,
müsste man, rational gesehen,
nonstop weinen über das ganze Leid,
das tagtäglich in der Welt passiert.
Mal ganz abgesehen
von der Irrationalität,
dass viele Menschen,
die sich von Schicksalen
einzelner Tiere bewegen lassen,
ohne Gewissensbisse Fleisch essen.
Jedenfalls - Empathie ist etwas
unglaublich faszinierendes,
dass uns Menschen zu Menschen macht.
D.h. aber gleichzeitig, dass es nicht
zwingend etwas Gutes ist.
Empathie veranlasst uns dazu,
anderen Menschen zu helfen.
Sie veranlasst uns
aber auch dazu, wegzuschauen.
Und wenn wir nicht aufpassen,
verschenken wir
unser Mitgefühl dahin,
wo es rational gesehen, nicht
unbedingt am meisten gebraucht wird.
Es kommt also immer darauf an,
wie wir unser Mitgefühl einsetzen.
Ein soziales Leben
ohne Empathie ist undenkbar.
Aber ohne rationales Denken
sind wir garantiert schlimmer
als unsere tierischen Freunde.
Das wichtige ist also eine
gute Balance, wie so oft im Leben.
Also setzt euer Mitgefühl und euren
Verstand gleichermaßen schlau ein.
Schönschlau zum Beispiel.
Und damit wünsche ich euch
wunderschöne Feiertage
und einen guten Rutsch ins neue Jahr.
Denn wir machen 2 Wochen Winterpause.
Wir sehen uns also erst 2018 wieder.
Bis dahin könnt ihr gerne
alle eure Fragen für das neue Jahr
in die Kommentare schreiben.
Wir sehen uns im Januar,
bis dahin, bleibt sicher.